Abderrazak besseguir un ami de la maison
vous étiez venu à l'époque où votre
affaire battait son plein vous êtes donc
l'ex bagagiste de Roissy injustement
soupçonné de terrorisme il y a 4 mois et
demi et finalement libéré quand il a été
patent que votre affaire en fait était
un complot monté par votre belle famille
les bescheries voilà donc là vous êtes
libre et vous publiez aujourd'hui un
livre qui s'appelle bagagiste à Roissy
présumé terroriste et sécher Michel
Lafon
[Musique]
je connais déjà
j'ai écrit le livre avec un journaliste
qui s'appelle Aziz et Mori à qui je
voulais rendre un hommage à la télé
c'était vraiment un grand journaliste
Votre situation s'est arrangée puisque
jeudi dernier Abderrazak bessègue vous
avez bénéficié dans le non-lieu
exactement donc ça c'est déjà un point
c'est déjà plutôt bien après quand même
presque 5 mois d'attente à tout à fait
mais enfin on est quand même loin de
voir la justice reconnaître son son
erreur et vous versez des indemnités
suite à votre incarcération quand même
pas encore aux indemnités mais on a déjà
de non lieu déjà pas mal c'est un début
alors d'autant plus que le patron de la
brigade criminelle Frédéric Pechenard
lui il est pas du tout d'accord avec
l'analyse que vous faites de ce qui vous
est arrivé lui il dit l'enquête a été
parfaite j'ai lu son article beaucoup de
méthodes beaucoup de sang-froid
vous répondez quoi ça je suis tout à
fait pas d'accord ouais ça on était
placé à deux extrémités donc forcément
on a chacun notre version c'est un
véritable que moi depuis le début je les
ai la vérité aujourd'hui je suis resté
sur ma ligne de mire je me dis que la
vérité si méthode est sans froid c'est
pas fait un innocent le jeu
c'est des claques donc là que même mon
père m'a pas mis donc et surtout pour un
innocence c'est du ravaler et puis quoi
d'autre sur l'enquête bah la manière
dont tu as été venue l'enquête c'était
tout de suite faut voir le titre du
livre présumé terroriste pourquoi mes
origines mon lieu de travail
ma religion surtout ma religion qui a
été bafouille pendant ces 15 jours
Abderrazak bessiguir avec une certaine
ironie par exemple vous dites qu'avant
il y a un chien policier qui est
spécialisé donc pour trouver les armes
et qui s'arrête sur le siège bébé de
votre voiture qui renive comme ça et en
fait c'est parce que la veille
dites-vous vous aviez acheté des merguez
que le chien il sentait l'odeur des
merguez maintenant aujourd'hui ce qui
est grave c'est que les policiers font
parler les chiens maintenant deux
abonnements c'est de la TNT trois
aboiements ça peut être des merguez en
Afrique 2 à la rigueur donc en tout cas
c'est des merguez c'était pas du TNT
alors plus grave quand même dans cette
histoire vous affirmez que que votre
oncle qui était en situation irrégulière
en France c'est vu proposer des papiers
s'il vous accusez de terrorisme c'est du
chantage ça
chantage plus récent et pas d'autres
mots je l'ai aussi bien entendu de la
bouche de mon oncle mais de la bouche
des policiers qui m'ont dit tout
simplement vraiment que toute ma famille
avouée m'avait culpabilisé
pour pour voir justement essayer de
soutirer des aveux quoi et sont plantés
et puis
ce que je connais ma famille je me
connais moi-même on a une certaine
fierté on a on est issu d'un on a été on
va dire élevé dans avec certaines
valeurs vous affirmez dans votre livre
que les journalistes ne font pas
d'enquête et se contentent de répéter ce
que dit la police c'est-à-dire de
finalement de communiquer les éléments
que leur donne la police vous affirmez
d'ailleurs que Nicolas Sarkozy a donné
lui-même des informations à la presse
oui je la ferme c'est à travers
justement
ce hémories Aziz qui est journaliste
lui-même
ce Nicolas Sarkozy si je peux dire
monsieur parce que moi on m'a pas appelé
du tout comme ça
de source sûre a reçu les journalistes
du fameux journal Le Parisien qui s'est
bien défoulé sur mon sur mon CAP pendant
ces 15 jours là en disant tout
simplement que que ça ait le téléphone
avait parlé donc ça venait pas de
n'importe qui donc si la plus grosse
autorité on va dire sur ce principe là
lâche le mot les policiers en bas ne
peuvent que suivre alors dans votre vie
vous accusez la presse vous accusez la
justice Vous accusez la police enfin
finalement ce qui vous est arrivé c'est
quand même la faute de votre belle
famille c'est quand même eux comment
créer ce qu'on veut quand il y a pas de
racisme puisqu'ils sont d'origine
algérienne comme vous c'est des
personnes que je veux plus en entendre
parler plus du tout de ces personnes là
donc je demanderai pas des applications
sur certaines personnes j'attends que la
justice fasse son travail et qu'après
quatre mois demandent un dépôt quand
même on relâche ces gens-là oui c'est ce
que j'allais vous dire la justice les a
relâché donc ça permet aujourd'hui
justement de se trimballer avec des
pains d'explosive qu'on risque à te
demander un dépôt donc vaut mieux se
balader avec la TNT plutôt que
d'arracher le sac d'une vieille
c'est que eux en fait ils vous ont mis
dans cette situation ils ont demandé à
quelqu'un de mettre des explosifs dans
votre dans votre automobile et
finalement aujourd'hui ils sont libres
vous y comprenez quelque chose non mais
je vous dis pas qu'elle dans quel cas je
me trouve quand je vois ça
quand votre épouse louisa est décédé
votre belle famille avait porté plainte
et ils disent quand on les interviews
ils disent que toute façon il vous
accuse du meurtre de de Louisa de de
votre femme et ils disent que finalement
vous n'avez été relâché que parce qu'on
avait pas de preuve c'est grave ça
franchement c'est très grave ça me
touche énormément plus que l'histoire du
terroriste parce que ma femme je
l'aimais avant tout c'est une personne
qui compte beaucoup pour moi
jusqu'aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
c'est une personne qui habite mes
pensées
jamais de ma vie j'ai eu approuvé à qui
que ce soit de toute façon ce qui s'est
passé maintenant si j'écris libre et que
j'en ai parlé dans ce livre là c'est
pour mon enfant avant tout
[Musique]
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais parce que vous arrivez vous
trouverez votre femme en feu et que
c'est vous qui les teniez qui lui permet
de vivre on va dire lueur d'espoir de
s'en sortir de moi je pense pas que
j'aurais parié avec la vie de ma femme
et la femme quoi c'est vraiment atroce
et c'est vraiment n'importe quoi
maintenant moi si je tiens à m'exprimer
par rapport à ça
c'est vrai qu'elle s'est mollet tout
seul
disons-le donc en présence de votre
enfant me dit si asperger doit être
Spirit et c'est mille-feu c'est
j'arriverai jamais à l'expliquer moi je
reste toujours avec cette question là
pourquoi le pourquoi du comment je le
serai jamais puisque la personne est
plus là personne ne peut expliquer un
geste comme ça c'est un geste intime
personnel et auquel jusqu'aujourd'hui
il y a d'autres façons de se suicider à
notre époque comme je vous ai dit
c'était intime et personnel donc je
pourrais je pourrais jamais le
comprendre aujourd'hui vous dites que
vous êtes aussi détruit qu'après le
décès de Louisa vous avez plus de
voitures vous êtes suivi par un
psychologue vous êtes sous
tranquillisant ça va pas mieux là
là je devais me Régis
chez ma mère et mon enfant et ainsi que
mes amis et m'approche famille qui sont
venus me récupérer à la sortie de la
prison
puis après il y avait plus rien comment
voulez-vous vous réadapter vos
réhabiliter dans cette société là c'est
la même société qui m'a mis dans cet
état-là je pense que la minimum j'aurais
peut-être reçu des excuses où j'ai
peut-être rencontré les personnes qui
m'ont peut-être giflées ou les personnes
qui ont commandité le fait qu'on
m'envoie en prison ou tout simplement
des excuses lorsque vous voyez des
journalistes qui s'expriment alors
qu'ils ont inventé une histoire de
mallette ils ont failli trouver un temps
que presque gare à Roissy et c'était pas
le trouver un tank mais ces gens là
aujourd'hui même à la télévision ils se
refuse de s'excuser c'est je sais pas où
on va quoi vous dites ma vie a été
violée c'est clair c'est clair
aujourd'hui ma vie m'appartient plus
puisque tout le monde sait ce qui se
passe dans ma vie quoi ce qui s'est
passé dans ma vie donc quelque part le
jardin secret on l'a pris
vous allez rester ici en France et les
continuer à vivre en France
à qui vous en voulez le plus aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
si je dois que faire dresser un podium
je dois dire numéro 1 la femme Vichy à
la belle-mère avec une mention spéciale
ensuite
à la police et médailles de bronze à la
justice parce que là c'est l'enquête de
police qui a été mal faite donc on peut
pas excuser
à la sortie quand même eu qu'un jour
quand même je sais pas quand vous avez
entre les mains une un témoignage qui
au niveau du timing ne correspond pas
vous avez une description de la personne
qui ne correspond pas lorsque vous
décrivez
à telle heure vous étiez là alors que
vous étiez pas là et que ils mettent 10
jours pour l'interroger ces mêmes
personnes là c'est la mauvaise foi
l'enquête c'était de la charge de la
charge la charge la décharge ou
l'étincelle de décharge est venu de ma
famille qui a bousculé un petit peu
c'est c'était trop gros
j'ai pas été licencié ou quoi que ce
soit au contraire la société a été
idéale sur ce point là
ils m'ont même très soutenu je suis en
arrêt maladie actuellement à savoir si
je vais reprendre mon boulot oui ou non
moi-même je ne sais pas aujourd'hui je
sors plus trop quoi je me sens bien très
bien chez moi dehors ça me fait encore
un peu peur aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
merci le livre s'appelle bagagiste à
Roissy présumé terroriste c'est éviter
chez Michel Lafont et c'est un livre
d'Abderrazak bcgy merci beaucoup écris
avec Aziz Zemmouri qui est aux Figaro
Magazine merci beaucoup au revoir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu